pour moins de plus ce système oh ouais
bah ouais quand même
[Musique]
bon aujourd'hui on va parler de lui ça
fait quelques jours ce carton est arrivé
au studio et j'avais vraiment hâte de
pouvoir vous en parler j'ai la chance
d'avoir reçu ce colis en avant première
grosse exclu je suis très très très
content tu donc vous présenter
aujourd'hui le web + 6 t parce qu'à
l'intérieur de ce carton il ya
effectivement le one fussistes et qui a
déjà remercié one plus qu'il a fait
confiance et qui m'a olalalala et qui
m'a envoyé ce colis en avant première
c'est juste incroyable dire que là
dedans vous avez un smartphone qui n'a
pas encore été présentée pas encore
annoncé que j'ai là que je peux pas
sortir que je veux pas montrer alors
j'ai envie de le partager le montrer à
tout le monde je n'ai strictement pas le
droit
c'est très frustrant mais très très
excitant même temps alors on regarde ce
qu'il y a à l'intérieur de cette boîte
joli petit courrier niamien ouvert de
michonne cher bestech bon tout un
courrier de présentation et la bim bam
boum
là c'est le one plus ce système qui est
juste dans sa boîte donc on va ouvrir
d'ici quelques instants
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a ici dans cette
boîte oh lalala lalala
donc là j'ai une coque effet carbone un
père joly qu'est ce que j'ai ici une
autre cac -2 plus pur loin de plus si ce
texte est grisé qu avons nous là une
offre coque tout rouge pour le vol + 6 t
et la caisse que nous avons nous avons
les écouteurs up vient par là les
écouteurs j'adore slogan là c'est très
très classe super bien fait ça s'ouvre
comme ça donc ils sont là j'ai mis à
regarder le packaging il est vraiment
fabuleux bestbuzz for life ici on
accroît une petite partie pour ni relevé
qu est-ce qui se lève va savoir où et le
packaging de ouf issime j'adore le
boulot est extrêmement bien fait on a
ici les petits écouteurs écouteurs en
usb type c est là qu est ce qu on a des
petits bouchons pour venir mettre sur
vos écouteurs ok cool ensuite qu'avons
nous à l'intérieur de la boîte qu'est ce
que c'est que ça c'est pour venir
nettoyer l'écran de son vin de plus ce
système parfait et la liesse
ça c'est pour attacher dans votre
bagnole si je dis pas de bêtises pour me
reposer votre voix de plus ce système
partout avec un système de ventouse
maintenant on va passer directement au
gros de la boîte
c'est à dire le one piece 6t directement
ici et là on arrive à sa plaisir voilà
donc la boîte du wan pucistes et ce qui
est très malin c'est effectivement
commencer par le one + community la
communauté moi j'ai le mil mike blake
128 giga j'ai fait exprès de ne rien
regarder sur ce one + 6 t en termes de
rumeur tenace comme ça pour vraiment
garder la surprise pour l'ouverture pour
le unboxing pendant vraiment à quoi il
ressemblait ce produit donc je suis
vraiment complètement innocent là dessus
je vous dit on à quelques jours de la
présentation lorsque je
ouvre donc juste pour l'instant je ne
sais absolument pas je pense que
vraiment vraiment en pleine découverte
autant quand je vais publier cette vidéo
on aura déjà tout vu faudra déjà
quasiment tous donc là je suis vraiment
pour moi tout de suite en explorateur
c'est vraiment hyper hyper cool commence
à faire sa ba voila moi j'adore je sais
pas si ça vaut bien la caméra le 6 il ya
un côté un petit peu aguerri sur le long
là c'est vachement sympa qu'on sent plus
à temps ou un plus si c'était au ouais
bah ouais quand même
on maximiser les performances de notre
capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée à
l'écran vous recommandons d'utiliser des
protections d'écran de one plus où nos
partenaires officiels
ok regardez sa minuscule encoches
minuscule encoches languette pour le
lever ps ah ouais
ah j'adore j'adore double capteur photo
ici à la verticale hop on va enlever ça
on va enlever ça aussi design by one
plus j'adore c'est vraiment très très
sobre hyper efficace double module photo
positionner si la verticale le petit
flash en dessous
qu'est ce qu'on a ici on a hop un petit
côté slide un bouton ici on a le bouton
de volume de tirua ici pour mettre vos
cartes sim sur le dessus ce doit être un
micro sur le dos ou bien évidemment de
l'usb type c'est incroyable
j'adore j'adore je trouve que c'est
vraiment extrêmement bien réussi alors
on va aller lui mais dans quelques
secondes on va regarder d'abord le reste
de la boîte ce que c'est quand même le
but de l'exercice
aujourd'hui ça ça s'enlève mais à
l'intérieur on a également une
protection génial génial ça veut dire
que si on l'achète et qu'on n'a pas tous
le coffret tout les coqs
on a quand même une coque à l'intérieur
une coque transparente
ça s'est vraiment bien points de plus
les mythes dans ça c'est cool voilà le
packaging
l'ouverture c'est vachement bien c'est
un c'est vachement bien fait yes yes i'm
flaccide killer j'adore des petits
messages hyper sympa c'est très rigolo
c'est vraiment bien fait tout dans
l'humour dans le détail dans la
précision
ici vous avez votre petite pépite
alterné gza power au lecteur de carte
sim
ici des informations sur votre
smartphone est là qu est ce qu on a
highway alors ils nous font ça on peut
format poster ça c'est très bien vu
pourrait presque l'affiché dans ma
chambre
ban locke de screen miller sitl y est
super bien
wahou invitational later une lettre
d'invitation alors attendez dans une
petite languette petit clan guette
j'adore le packaging est extrêmement
bien fait bien penser une ouverture à
tous les niveaux différents degrés de
lecture un mot de pete le cio de one
plus et on a une petite partie petite
encoche lahlou et c'est très drôle
poppen j'adore mais franchement le
détail la fabrication c'est incroyable
vous avez la petite lucky mot manuscrit
qui est l'art friends l'arrivée des
forces nouvelles communautés nouvelles
plus que les tubes ok je vais éviter de
vous passer je vais me lire
tranquillement mais je trouve que c'est
vachement bien
vraiment le boulot là dessus en terme de
packaging c'est juste dingue on a donc
ici up pendant notre bloc de recharge
pour avoir la recharge rapide là dessus
j'adore bien évidemment le cordon tout
rouge en usb type c'est magnifique et ça
c'est bien parce que ça a disparu un peu
et de la concurrence notamment d'apple
l'adaptateur port jack vers ios bêtise
c'est très bon pour une plus parce que
là dessus je sais pas si vous avez vu
sur loing de plus 6 t il y a bien
évidemment absolument aucune prise jack
donc c'est très bien qu'il l'ait mis la
même si effectivement je suis pas un
très très gros fan de seat acteurs parce
que vous avez un truc qui pendouille
c'est parce qu'elle mieux bon la
meilleure solution reste quand même les
écouteurs en usd type c malgré tout ça
peut quand même avoir un côté très
pratique il ya un vrai beau boulot a été
fait de la part des équipes de bonnes
plus sur le packaging vraiment hyper
soignée hyper hyper hyper qualitatif que
maintenant on va aller un peu plus loin
ont valu mais loin de plus 6 t on avoir
un petit peu ce qui nous raconte une
histoire premier allumage du grain plus
ce système utilisé
visage et votre empreinte digitale pour
déverrouiller comment utiliser
l'empreinte digitale veuille appuyé avec
votre doigt dans la zone
d'identification puis le soulever après
la vibration
c'est hyper drôle de le faire
directement sur l'écran j'ai vite eu le
faire sur des capteurs d'empreintes
digitales un peu classique et là d'avoir
le capteur qui est directement intégré à
l'écran c'est vraiment hyper hyper
bizarre parce que je ne repars pas loria
petite zone c'est incroyable c'est ouf
empreintes digitales a ajouté
yes regardez-moi ça l'enclencher tout
petit c'est juste ou fille sim je le
trouve vraiment magnifique
en termes de prise en main hyper hyper
hyper agréable alors on va tester pour
le déverrouiller directement je prends à
il a reconnu mon visage je me cache
diary caméra j'appuie fois la bâche
regardez ça vous fait l'espèce deux des
cinq ans je le déverrouiller c'est ouf
je me plante derrière la caméra
hop on ne voit pas j'apparais c'est
hyper rapide incroyable j'en profite
pour vous montrer les trois coques ses
sorties de leur étui elles sont là
la toute première elle est hyper douce
on a un côté un peu toucher velours
c'est vraiment hyper hyper agréable elle
est juste ouverte un peu sur le bas il
ya un côté un peu alcantara l'intérieur
c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper
agréable
pas mal je pense à ses classes à celle
là elle a un côté un peu plus rugueux un
peu plus rugueux ouverte sur le haut et
ouverte sur le bas j'aime bien tout ça
assez classe il ya un côté très premium
derrière avec cette coque et la
troisième qui a un côté un peu matière
aussi gras c'est pareil parce qu'on
entendait bien ça fait beaucoup de bruit
ça sert un peu c'est marrant très doux à
l'intérieur celle-là lénine ouverte sur
l'eau n'est ouverte sur le bas et je
trouve ça franchement pas mal je trouve
ça même plutôt classe voilà pour ce
boxing nouvelle puce system je suis
impatient de vous le faire découvrir
je sais comment vous allez regarder
cette vidéo il aura été présenté il sera
officiel mais moi quand je le ton tout
de suite il reste encore plusieurs jours
à attendre avant de pouvoir vous le des
volets et croyez moi la tente est
vraiment vraiment vraiment hyper dur je
sens en même temps ma vidéo test comme
ça vous saurez tout vous aurez le boxing
le test carrément on y va comme ça alors
après je sortirai une autre vidéo un peu
plus tard de tests de photos vidéos
comme ça on en reparlera tranquillement
et puis y aura probablement d'autres
vidéos qui arriveront par la suite mais
ça pour l'instant je garde encore un
petit peu de suspense on verra tout ça
plus tard merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo dites-moi sq
pensez de ce roi de plus si c'était
comment vous trouvez est ce que vous
trouvez bien réussi qu est ce que vous
pensez de cette toute petite encoche
euros est ce que vous aimez ça on voit
que les encoches commencent à
disparaître
schumi a présenté son 1000 x 3 l'autre
jour en chine pas encore en europe qui
n'a pas du tout une encoche avec un
petit tiroir contenir sortir l'appareil
photo dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous trouvez que le système
de bonnes plus avoir une mini encoches
en forme de v c'est plus astucieux oui
non vous ne marquez tout ça bien
évidemment on reste connectés on le
teste on fait plein de choses on va
tester aussi plein de produits donc ça
c'est super cool merci à vous vous
marrez tout ça je vous donne rendez vous
très bientôt
[Musique]